Unreal Engine fully supports eye and hair shaders with Path Tracer.
Additionally, we can use material parameters to selectively control glass absorption.
All of these will be automatically calculated based on the shading model of the material,
which can be modified in the parent material under Material, Shading Model.
Unreal Engine also has the ability to leverage energy conservation on materials.
You can enable this setting in the Project Settings under Engine, Rendering, Material section,
and ensure that the Enable Energy Conservation on Material parameter is checked.
Now, depending on the nature of your project or your intended target hardware,
you may opt to create fallbacks for non-path tracing configurations within your materials.
You can create a simplified material for ray tracing by using the Path Tracing Quality Switch Replace node
This can improve performance while still allowing the engine to use a more complex material on non-ray traced viewports or hardware.